we are announcing 17 specific sanctions
against Iran's largest steel and iron
manufacturers set three seychelles based
entities and a vessel involved in the
transfer of products as a result of
these actions we will cut off billions
of dollars of support to the Iranian
regime and we will continue our
enforcement of other entities today's
sanctions are part of our commitment to
stop the Iranian regime's global
terrorist activities the president has
been very clear we will continue to
apply economic sanctions until Iran
stops its terrorist activities and
commits that it will never have nuclear
weapons so we have several
correspondents monitoring these latest
developments Osama bin Javed is in
Baghdad Dorset Jabari isn't Tehran for
reaction to those new sanctions we'll be
speaking to them shortly but first we'll
cross over to a White House
correspondent Kimberly halket this is
something that the president had said
would happen Kimberly now we've heard
the details from the Secretary of State
and the Secretary of the Treasury yeah
another round doreen of sanctions by the
Trump administration you have to
remember that the first round of
sanctions as part of its broader maximum
pressure campaign as they call it
started when the United States withdrew
from the jcpoa or that agreement to
limit Iran's nuclear program those
snack-bot sanctions put in place since
then two more rounds of sanctions now we
have yet another and the administration
very clear the reason for these
sanctions retaliation for Iran's attacks
on those two bases this week inside Iraq
that also house US military now the as
you outlined there the sanctions are
extensive they cut in front the steel
and iron industries as well as trade
construction mining textiles all the
sectors of the economy that the United
States feels this would further inflict
financial pain the goal very clear from
the Treasury secretary the desire of
this administration is not only to
isolate Iran from the global financial
system but also to [ __ ] its economy
and Kimberly the Secretary of State
Pompeyo reiterating once again at that
press conference to journalists that
Qasem Soleimani was plotting according
to Pompeo a large-scale attack on US
embassies as well as other facilities
but not really providing any evidence
and this has been the ongoing issue for
this administration since there was this
strike to assassinate the Iranian
general essentially the concern has been
here in the United States that Donald
Trump may have taken this action to
distract from what would have been going
on in the one we would have been
covering this week in the Washington and
that is the start of the trial in the US
Senate to impeach the president instead
this is what is dominating headlines and
the United States says that it is
focused on foreign policy it's concerned
about potentially even diplomacy with
Iran and they say they don't want war at
the same time they said they had to take
this action because unmistakeably they
said that they had intelligence that has
not been provided to Congress or to the
American public that there was an
imminent threat to US interests this was
gonna happen and American lives were
risk and we would have been culpably
negligent as the chairman of the Joint
Chiefs assessed said we would have been
culpably negligent and we now
recommended the president that he take
this action in Qasem Soleimani he made
the right call and America is safer as a
result of that now the US president has
suggested that that potential threat
could even have included the embassy the
US Embassy in Baghdad but again no
information or evidence provided by the
intrud ministration instead all they're
saying is trust us all right Kimberly
thank you for that update from
Washington let's now cross over to
Dorsett Jabari she's joining us from
Tehran as we're seeing a raft of new
sanctions announced on Iran what are you
hearing from where you are dorsal well
these sanctions are not likely to have
much effect on the people that have them
have been under sanctions now this is
something that's seen more as a
political gesture rather than actual
factual one because the United States
government knows that these names that
they've sanctioned they have no interest
in the United States they have no funds
in the u.s. they don't own any property
in the US and they don't
I'm traveling to the United States at
any point one of the top names on that
list is the Secretary of the Supreme
National Security Council of Iran Elisha
honey who is a very well known figure
here he is the secretary of this body
who's in charge of making decisions
about Iran's foreign policy as well as
its nuclear program under the guidance
and supervision of the supreme leader
his name is very well recognized here so
he's seen as a top official as well as
the head of the besieged forces that is
the volunteer force of the Revolutionary
Guards who is now under US sanctions
these are all going to be seen as a
political move for the United States to
try and save face in light of what
happened the airstrike the missile
strikes on their base in Iraq this is
how the Iranians will see it the other
thing to point out is that Secretary of
State Mark Pompeo believes that by
assassinating Awesome Soleimani the
United States is much safer now and is
according to the Iranians just the
opposites the United States troops in
the Middle East are now at much greater
risk the Iranians are demanding that
they leave this region completely after
the assassination of Qasem Soleimani so
all this coming together to really
create more divisions and tensions
between the two sides rather than trying
to come to terms with what has happened
over the past few days okay Georgia
thank you